Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 271 mit einem Thema, von dem ihr sicherlich noch gar nichts gehört habt und das euer Herz hoch erfreut, wenn ihr es hört. Es geht um Cybersicherheitspolitik im Rahmen der Bundestagswahl. Ja, es ist notwendig. Man würde es eigentlich den Leuten gerne ersparen, aber das geht nicht, weil es ja verschiedene Aspekte gibt, die möglicherweise für eine Wahlentscheidung ausschlaggebend sind. Und dann ist klar, also gut, Chaosradio macht dann wahrscheinlich sozusagen nicht den Teil, wo wir die Erde mit Klimaschutz retten, auch wichtig, sondern irgendwas mit dem Digitalen. Aber selbst das ist mittlerweile so groß, dass eine Sendung, vielleicht würde man es schaffen, aber die Gehirne werden danach weich. Deswegen konzentrieren wir uns heute auf ein Thema, nämlich Cybersicherheitspolitik. Was das genau ist, muss ich gleich noch fragen. Und dazu begrüße ich recht herzlich Honkaase. Hallo. Wer ist das? Honkaase kennt ihr vielleicht von vergangenen Chaosradio Sendungen. Das letzte Mal als wir uns gehört haben, war es, glaube ich, kritische Infrastruktur und warum das auch wichtig ist. Markus ist auch k.o. macht Datenschutzdinger und IT-Krams. Und man hat in der letzten Zeit vielleicht von ihm gehört, weil er sehr umtriebig auch ist öffentlich. Und Anna ist bei netzpolitik.org CVD gerade, vor allem. Also man liest gerade nicht so viel von ihr, weil sie an der Front sitzt. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Radiobeitrag mache, dann gehe ich zum CVD und dann sagt er, also hier musst du aber noch. Er sagt meistens im Prinzip gut, aber... Und dann, naja gut, das ist eine andere Geschichte. Wir wollen heute über Cyber-Sicherheitspolitik reden. Und vielleicht könnt ihr euch gleich noch mal vorstellen, mit eurer liebsten Cyber-Sicherheitspolitik-Geschichte, mit der ihr persönlich zu tun hattet, im Rahmen der letzten Legislaturperiode. Honkase.
Ja, also es gab da sozusagen die Idee, wir hängen ein bisschen hinterher. Und China und die USA sind ganz weit vorne bei irgendwas, innovativen. Und deswegen müssen wir jetzt quasi sehr viel Geld ausgeben, um aufzuholen. So ein bisschen wie früher im Kalten Krieg das Wetteristen. Wir müssen ein bisschen aufholen. Und dazu wollen wir eine Sprung Innovation machen. Und da hat man zwei Agenturen gegründet. Eine für zivile Innovation und eine für Innovation in der Cybersicherheit, die ADIC. Und da gab es dann sowohl das Projekt GaiaX, wo sich quasi Open Source Befürworter versammelt haben und dann der Regierung im Rahmen von diesem digitalen Severänitätsdebatten verkauft haben, dass man doch jetzt ein europäisches, sicheres Open Source Cloud System bauen müsste, damit man hier in Europa sicher und souverän Cloud-Dienste betreiben kann. Und das ist jetzt mal was, das man so zum Teil gut finden kann und zum Teil auch schwierig findet. Ich finde den Open Source Teil gut. Über das Setting und die Art und Weise, wie es gemacht wird, kann man vielleicht darüber reden, aber im Prinzip fand ich, dass man einen positiven Aspekt des Open Source da, wenn auch mit einer komischen Begründung, eine Förderung erhält.
Das andere Ding ist, wenn man jetzt Cloud sagt, wäre jetzt mein Verdacht, dass es eigentlich nicht die clevere Idee ist, einen weiteren zentralen Service zu machen, sondern dass man eher eine Technologie entwickeln wollen würde, die diese Technologie Leuten zur Verfügung stellt, die diese dann selber betreiben können, oder in Genossenschaften oder sowas?
Ja, die Idee ist quasi, dass wir die verschiedenen Rechenzentren in Europa so einen gemeinsamen Stack anbieten, dass du halt auch zwischen verschiedenen Rechenzentren deine Services verschieben kannst, dass du halt diese vielen kleinen Anbieter in Europa zu einem größeren virtuellen Service zusammenbilden kannst.
Und heißt das, diese Agentur ist sozusagen eine sinnvolle Einrichtung gewesen oder eher sehr viel heiße Luft um nichts?
Naja, ich finde halt so Agenturen in Form einer GmbH immer schwierig, weil es halt so eine Art Schattenhaushalt wird. Du steckst halt viel Geld rein, hast aber keine öffentliche Kontrolle darüber, was damit passiert. Und als Staat sollte man schon dafür sorgen, dass wir eine maschinenläsbare Regierung haben, eine alte Chaos-Forderung und das heißt halt auch ein offener Haushalt.
Ich würde noch ein consumerorientiertes Thema, eine consumerorientierte Frage stellen wollen. Auch auf die Gefahren, dass ich vielleicht sage, das hat gar nichts damit zu tun, aber irgendwie doch. Und zwar kommt der Gedanke daraus, es gab neulich, was war denn, Osram. Osram hatte glaube ich so ein Home-Automation-Dings. Und da schalten sie jetzt die Server ab, und wenn man sich nicht rechtzeitig kümmert, hat man dann Glühlampen, die nicht mehr funktionieren. Und diese ganze Diskussion hat mich auf die Idee gebracht, dass das gibt es ja auch, also ein Teil von Cyber-Sicherheit ist ja auch die Sicherheit meiner privaten Infrastruktur. Da gibt es immer diese Frage, dürfen Leute oder Firmen ihre Router irgendwie zumachen, dass da gar keine mehr Kontrolle drüber hat? Kann man die verpflichten, dass sie irgendwie wenigstens x Jahre nach verkauft, dass sie der Patches nachreichen müssen? Und diese ganzen Sachen eher so, was ganz sehr kleines, frickeliges, detailhaftes, was aber glaube ich im einzelnen Leben immer wichtig ist. Ist das auch überhaupt ein Thema gewesen, so was? Oder fällt das für euch da ganz raus? Oder lohnt gar nicht, weil es zu kleinteilig ist?
Nö, es ist ein wichtiges Thema und ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wer vom CCC, aber in einer Anhörung hatte angebracht, dass man bei Software durchaus mal nachdenken sollte, um ein Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum einzuführen, damit es einfach auch eine garantierte Zeit gibt, in der ich weiß, die ist funktional und kann sicher betrieben werden. Spätestens, wenn du in Richtung kritische Infrastrukturen abbiegst, wird es unheimlich schwer, weil die teilweise Komponenten einsetzen, die Jahrzehnte betrieben werden. Und wenn du dann Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum von zwei oder fünf Jahren hast, dann lachen die einmal herzlich. Ein Flugzeug ab Design bis zur Stilllegung des letzten Fliegers kann 50 Jahre in Anspruch nehmen. Damit erstegst du auch nicht alles, aber zumindest für Konsumer, so wie du gerade angesprochen hast, könnte man mit so einem Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum schon viel erreichen, dass die Firmen da eben nicht nur auf die Wirtschaftlichkeit gucken, sondern sagen, na gut, dann müssen wir doch in sichere Softwareentwicklung mal ein bisschen mehr investieren. Denn die Abläufe und die Prozesse, wie man sichere Software entwickelt, Secure by Design, Secure by Default und so, gibt es alles. Das ist alles vorhanden, aber es wird selten ordentlich umgesetzt, weil eben keine Notwendigkeit da ist.
Es gab jetzt auch eine EU-Richtlinie zu dem Thema, zum Thema digitale Produkte und Kauf von digitalen Inhalten und Dienstleistungen. Das ist auch in ein Gesetz umgewandelt worden. Und ich glaube, ab 2022 bekommen dann Verbraucherinnen mehr Rechte. Es gibt auch zum Teil eine Updatepflicht für Unternehmen, dass sie ihre Produkte halt im Rahmen einer gewissen Frist, die sie sich selber setzen können, dann quasi mit funktionserhaltenden Updates versorgen. Das ist aber eine relativ neue Regelung. Daher gibt es vielleicht noch nicht viel, was die Implementierung angeht oder die Umsetzung.
Und die Regelung, die bezieht sich nur auf Software oder Dienstleistungsprodukte?
Auf digitale Produkte. Es gibt verschiedene Kategorien von Produkten. Ob ich jetzt ein E-Book kaufe oder ob ich digitales Fernsehen mir einkaufe oder Video-and-Demand-Dienste oder ob ich mir quasi ein intelligentes Glühbirnsystem hole. Da gibt es verschiedene Kategorien, die dann verschiedene Service Level erfüllen müssen.
Das heißt sozusagen, das ist eine gute Idee, die aber noch nicht explizit genug ist?
Hab ich das richtig verstanden? Es gibt dazu jetzt ein Gesetz, das ist halt neu. Es tritt dann nächstes Jahr an Kraft. Wir können das ja nachher mal verlinken in den Show Notes. Aber zu den genauen Regeln kann ich jetzt auch nicht so viel sagen. Ich hatte das mal gelesen, aber das ist schon eine Weile her.
Okay. Haben die anderen beiden da noch irgendwie zu dem Ding, oder was in dem Wahlprogramm steht? Wisst ihr da noch, was vielleicht?
Ich glaube, die Linke hat sich tatsächlich explizit reingeschrieben, so Produkthaftung für Hersteller auszuweiten. Bei den anderen habe ich gerade gar nicht so den Überblick, aber ich glaube einfach, es ist ein unglaublich wichtiges Thema, weil ansonsten ja Personen einfach... Doch die FDP hat sich es auch reingeschrieben. Und ich glaube, es ist eben nicht so kleinteilig, sondern schon eines der wichtigeren Themen, weil ich glaube, dadurch, dass Hersteller eben wissen, dass sie im Zweifelsfall zur Verantwortung gezogen werden können, müssen sie ja auch ihre Prozesse umstellen, eben hin zu einer IT-Sicherheit, die nicht irgendwie nachträglich so ein bisschen sorgenkindmäßig draufgepfropft wird, sondern so, dass es sich dann eben, dass es eben auch für die Hersteller im Nachhinein nicht schmerzhaft wird, wenn sie dann eben haften müssen. Und ich glaube, das kann einfach auch ein bisschen so die ganze Produktionsmoral ein bisschen umdrehen im besten Fall. Und das hilft ja dann nicht nur den Leuten, die dann sich eine Glühbirne installieren, sondern auch vielen anderen.
Das ist eh dann ein Thema, wo wir jetzt gefühlt sozusagen so ein bisschen hinsteuern. Weil ich habe den Eindruck, wann immer man was Konkretes fragt, ist so, kann man sagen, was in den letzten Jahren gelaufen wird, fällt dann unter die Kategorie, fällt bestenfalls unter die Kategorie, es ist nicht vollständig kaputt. Aber ist dann irgendwie kompliziert. Können wir vielleicht eine Ebene größer gehen und sagen, also die deutsche, nicht nur Cyber-Sicherheitspolitik, sondern Digitalpolitik wirkt auf mich immer wie so ein Hinterherrennen. Also andere Länder sind weiter, wenn man das schon hört. Oder wir brauchen mehr Sicherheit. Das heißt, es scheint so gar nicht so ein langfristiges zu geben sein. Es gibt immer nur so ein Gepätsche. Gibt es mittlerweile in der Politik, wo man sagen kann, naja, das Konkreteste ist der eine, aber die haben wenigstens langfristig eine Perspektive, wo es hingehen kann? Also die wissen überhaupt, was man machen muss? Oder bleibt das bei allen politischen Kräften in diesem kleinen Kleinen?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich es hinterherrennen würde. Ich würde es eher Inkonsequenz nennen. Ich glaube, an vielen Stellen ist es gar nicht so, dass man hinkt großartig hinterher, sondern man kann sich einfach nicht für eine echte IT-Sicherheit entscheiden. Man hat immer noch nicht verstanden, dass wenn ich jetzt über IT-Sicherheit rede, dass dann eben Verteidigung auch die beste Verteidigung ist. Und dass ich mir das dann nicht irgendwie so zurechtlege, dass ich den ganzen anderen Kram, den meine Behörden, meine Geheimdienste und sonst wer gerne noch machen würde, irgendwie dann noch ermögliche und damit wieder alles kaputt mache. Also ich glaube, man bräuchte schon mehr Konsequenz und vielleicht nicht mal so sehr dieses sich an irgendeine Spitze von einer Entwicklung stellen.
Ich mach das nächste Fass auf, was du dann gleich anzünden möchtest, weil ich es auch schon mehrfach brandrohnen wollte. Also was man dafür braucht, ist eine ganz klare Cybersicherheitsstrategie. Und wir haben eine Cybersicherheitsstrategie 2016 vom Bundesinnenministerium verarbeitet bekommen.
Welche Farbe hat er das damals?
Union, ja. Also es ist CDU gefärbt und naja, dann weiß er schon meine Meinung dazu. Aber ich sag's trotzdem. Das Ding heißt Cybersicherheitsstrategie 2016. Und es hat nichts, aber auch wirklich gar nichts mit einer Strategie zu tun. Es sind lieblos auf 34 Seiten oder so ein paar Maßnahmen zusammengeklatscht worden, die überhaupt kein strategisches Ziel verfolgen. Keine KPI-Messpunkte, an denen du bewerten willst, ob und welche Punkte du erfüllt hast. Also wirklich lieblos ist das. Ich hab noch nie so ein strategieloses Strategiepapier gesehen. Dafür schäme ich mich. So. Fremdschämen. Und es hat letztes Jahr vier Workshops gegeben, in denen das BMI gesagt hat, ja hier ist Cybersicherheitsstrategie 2021, wir machen ein Update. Und wollen jetzt alle beteiligen. Und dann waren da Sicherheitsbehörden, Professoren, also die Wissenschaft sozusagen. Die AG Critis wurde sogar auch eingeladen und ein paar andere und durften an diesen Workshops teilnehmen. Und dann war ich in zwei von den vieren, weil in den anderen zwei war Ion von der AG Critis mit dabei. Und wir haben uns, also erstmal war so, es wurde immer wieder implizit klar, es gibt eine feste Roadmap, feste Vorgehensweise. Und die haben mal aus initial gesammelten Feedbacks so Thesen aufgeschrieben. Die passten aber irgendwie vorne und hinten nicht. Und dann hat man darüber diskutiert und gesagt, aber diese These, also meinen sie die so oder so? Und man sollte dann von eins bis zehn Punkte dafür abstimmen, wie sehr man diese These vertritt. Und dann haben wir festgestellt an manchen Stellen, diese These ist sinnlos. Da haben nicht nur die Zivilgesellschaftlichen, sondern auch die Wissenschaftler oder teilweise sogar die Sicherheitsbehörden gesagt, ja, wenn das so umgemeint ist, dann ja. Aber wenn das so umgemeint ist, macht das ja keinen Sinn. Und dann haben die aber gesagt, ja, ne, die Frage ist jetzt so, die müssen sie so nehmen, die können wir auch nicht ändern, weil danach geht es ja weiter. Und dann wurde irgendwie nach ewiger Diskussion gesagt, ja, dann würden wir das so und so leicht abwandeln, dann nehmen sie das aus der Sicht. Und trotzdem hieß es dann aber am Ende, ja, wenn sie ihre Meinung abgegeben haben und ihre Bewertung der 1 bis 10 Punkte, dann ist das jetzt abgegeben. Und dann machen wir daraus den Entwurf der Strategie. Und da hatte dann noch ein Wissenschaftler und einer aus den Sicherheitsbehörden nachgefragt und gesagt, ja, Moment, ihr pollt jetzt unser Feedback ab, und wir haben schon gemerkt, dass diese Thesen und Fragen nicht ganz sinnvoll sind. Und dann müsste es doch Folgeworkshops und vielleicht noch mal das Feedback zusammensammeln und gucken. Das wird ja sehr divergent ausfallen. Und da hieß es so, nee, ist nicht vorgesehen in der Roadmap. Mitte nächstes Jahr kommt der Entwurf, und das muss dann bis Ende der Legislaturperiode fertig sein. Und eigentlich haben wir hier einen Wirtschaftsprüfer, der das Programm schon für uns durchzieht. Und links und rechts können wir auch nicht gucken, weil BMI-Zuständigkeit ist nur für hier. Weil wir haben gesagt, da fehlt nebenbei Kommunen, Länder, die Wissenschaft, ist alles vergessen worden in dieser Strategie. Und da hieß es dann, ja, aber da haben wir ja keine Zuständigkeit für. Und die Frage zu sagen, naja, vielleicht hebt man diese Seibesicherheitsstrategie vom BMI einer Zuständigkeit sehr eingeschränkt, vielleicht auf so was wie IT-Planungsrat oder wo auch immer, wo man ganz Deutschland vielleicht mal adressiert, hieß es dann, ja, nee, das ist jetzt hier aufgehangen, und der ist da zuständig, und da können wir ja nicht einfach wegnehmen. Also, und wenn man in diesen Entwurf 2021 reinguckt, Holla, die Waldfee, das ist ungefähr noch gruseliger als das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz 2 mit so manchen Aussagen und Statements, die da drin stehen, das kann man eigentlich auch nur in der Luft zerreißen, da wird keine sinnvolle Strategie rauskommen. Und das heißt, auch für die nächste Zeit gibt es eine strategielose Cyber-Umsetzung dieser Regierung noch.
Vielleicht sollte ich mir in meinen Soundtool hier mal so ein Flammenwerfergeräusch einbauen. Das würde die Sache wahrscheinlich ein bisschen erfahren. Okay, also das heißt, bekämen wir dieselbe GroKo wieder, dann würde das genauso weiterlaufen. Gibt es bei anderen Parteien Bestrebungen, ein, warte, lass es mich umfassen, glaubhafte Bestrebungen, eine langfristige Strategie, sich überhaupt ausdenken zu wollen?
Schweigen.
Es ist auch eine Frage. Moment, aber es ist speziell, ich meine, auch auf die Gefahr hin sozusagen, dass dieser Vergleich, wie alle Vergleiche, mega krass hinkt. Was den Klimawandel angeht, gibt es ja sozusagen Dinge, die wir tun können, also konkrete, großartige Ziele. Und es gibt aber tatsächlich sozusagen ganz klare, langfristige Ansagen, wo wir hinmüssen. Also es gibt ein großes Ziel und daraus leiten sich irgendwie kleinere Ziele etc. Und es scheint es hier also überhaupt gar nicht zu geben.
Weil immer jemand wie der Lindner um die Ecke kommt und dann sagt, digital first, bedenken second und dann denkst du so, oh Gott, gib mir einen Octopus, weil die Finger auf der Hand reichen nicht mehr aus für den Facepalm. Du findest einfach in jeder Partei solche Fails. Und deswegen digitale, wirklich so Cybersicherheitsstrategie für Deutschland. Ich glaube, das ist eine Einöde, da kannst du nur alles anzünden. Brandroden, einmal komplett.
Also wenn das Konzept mich schon grandios gescheitert wäre, würde ich fast sagen, es bräuchte mal so eine Partei, die voll politisch ist, aber da einen Schwerpunkt hat. Meine Güte, ist das frustrierend.
Das Thema selbst ist ja auch in diversen Parteien drin. Auch zum Teil mit größeren Zielen, wobei die Wahlprogramme in der Regel mit konkreteren Maßnahmen beschrieben sind, was in den nächsten vier Jahren passieren soll. Und weniger die weichen Grundsatzpositionen wiedergeben. Es gibt bei vielen Parteien Grundsatzprogramme, und dann gibt es Wahlprogramme, die konkrete Maßnahmen für die nächsten vier Jahre beinhalten. Das ist strukturell schwierig, diese Frage zu beantworten. Zum anderen ist das Thema Cyber-Sicherheit auch so eins, wo man vom Wording her auch ein bisschen gucken muss. Viele sprechen auch gerne von der IT-Sicherheit. Weil Cyber ja auch immer gerne schon ein bisschen militärisch vorgeprägt ist. Ob man jetzt irgendwie die Bundeswehr hat, die dann plötzlich irgendwie in der Kommune schützen soll oder das Kraftwerk von nebenan. Dass die da irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Soldaten auf die Leitung stellen und dann kontrollieren sie die Pakete. Also ich weiß nicht, wie sie das davor haben, aber wir haben ja sozusagen in allen Parteien, auch gerade in den Oppositionsparteien, viele Vorschläge für präventive, defensive Sicherheitsstrategien. Was man halt machen kann, um auch sozusagen in der Gesellschaft und der Wirtschaft grundsätzlich sichere Kommunikation zu ermöglichen. Das fängt ja bei so Dingen an, wie kann ich mich irgendwo ausweisen, mit einem E-Perso oder mit einem Chip im Handy, um halt irgendwie sicher mir meinen Covid-Zertifikat zu holen. Das sind ja alles so Dinge, wo wir schon an den Basistechnologien scheitern. Und deswegen auch wenig sichere Kommunikation.
Oder willst du grad vielleicht auch nochmal auf eine Luca-App anspielen, die total super und sicher entwickelt wurde, oh mein Gott. Nein, bei mir nicht. Ich hab einen scheiß Thread, der bei Twitter über 830 oder so Einträge inzwischen hat, wie kaputt das alles ist. Du kannst aber so einen Thread eigentlich zu jedem Cyberthema in Deutschland irgendwie bauen. Das ist möglich. Das ist irgendwie unglaublich.
Vielleicht muss ich mal, bevor ich mich in der Frustration vollständig hingebe, ist es eigentlich in anderen Ländern auch so, dass dieses IT-Thema, dieses Digitalisierungsthema immer so ein Rum mehr anderen zwischen FacePalm und Flammenwerfer ist?
Ich glaube tatsächlich, also nicht überall. Es gibt ja schon sehr viele Unterschiede, ob ich jetzt nach Skandinavien gucke oder nach Estland oder in die USA, wo man auch deutlich weniger Föderalismus hat, wo einfach zentral gesagt wird, okay, ich mache jetzt hier so eine Sicherheitsanweisung, halt wegen alle müssen jetzt ihre Exchange Server abschalten und patchen. Das ist in den USA halt quasi eine zentrale Stelle, die das mal rausgibt. Und hier hat man halt so Bund, Länder und Kommunen. Und dann die Beteiligung der Kommunen. Und da arbeitet jeweils die IT-Abteilung für sich selbst, ohne irgendwie großartig mit anderen sich abzustimmen oder gemeinsam Bedienungen zu betreiben. Es gibt natürlich so ein paar gemeinsame Rechenzentren. Aber die Synergieeffekte, die man jetzt in der großen Ordnung hätte, gesamte Verwaltung werden halt gar nicht benutzt.
Ja, aber dafür haben sie im Gegenzug dann so einen US-Präsident Biden, der sich hinstellt und sagt, wenn ihr Cyber-Ingriffe gegen USA fährt, dann werden wir mit kinetischen Wirkmitteln antworten. Und sagt quasi, cybert ihr uns an, schicken wir euch Bomben zurück. Das willst du dann aber eigentlich auch nicht, ne?
Das haben wir glaube ich auch schon in dem Weißbuch gehabt von der NATO 2011 oder so. Ich erinnere mich daran, dass die NATO damals das Wort Haktivisten benutzt hat. Und Haktivisten waren ja auch damals Leute, die irgendwie im Rahmen von dem Arabischen Frühling noch irgendwie Dienste aufgemacht haben oder Web-Sperren umgangen haben und solche Geschichten. Da gab es ja recht viel Aktivismus in dem Bereich.
Okay, also ich will noch ein letztes konkretes Thema anfangen. Vielleicht keine gute Idee, anyways, ich frag's trotzdem. Und zwar, wenn wir über sozusagen IT-Sicherheit sprechen, dann geht's ja auch ein bisschen, sagen, um die Digitalisierung des Verwaltungsapparates. Weil eigentlich will man, dass der Verwaltungsapparat, Behördengänge etc. dass sie digital auch vorangehen können oder auch im Gesundheitssystem. Andererseits fürchtet man sich immer davor, wie denn die Umsetzung aussieht. Und dann ist ja eben auch die Frage, ist das sicher? Könnt ihr was dazu sagen, wie der Stand da ist?
Also wer da ganz viel Langeweile hat, kann der Lilith auf Twitter folgen und sich angucken, wie dermaßen das vor die Wand gefahren wird.
Also es gibt ein Gesetz, das vorschreibt, dass alle Verwaltungsleistungen online gestellt werden müssen, dass man sie quasi online beantragen kann. Als OZG, ne? Da gab es auch eine Frist dazu, die wird aber leider nicht mehr eingehalten. Aber die Idee ist, man macht es erst mal alles online. Das heißt, man baut ein großes Portal, wo man Formulare ausfüllen kann. Und dann müssen die irgendwie ins Backend. Und dass man das Backend vielleicht auch digital haben sollte, das fiel denen dann anschließend auf. Und nun ja, wenn man halt so was strategisch angeht, mit dem Ziel zuerst mal die Webseite mit den Formularen und dann den Rest später, dann zieht es halt so parallel ein bisschen nach, mit ein bisschen Verzögerung. Dann hat man so Komponenten, die online sind, und Komponenten, die nicht online sind, und die noch zusammenwirken müssen. Dann hatte man noch diese Fachverfahren, die doch von sehr kleinen Herstellerbooten erstellt worden sind und auch rundaus laufen und aussehen wie aus den 90ern. Dann ist es halt schwierig, das sozusagen zentral mal neu zu machen. Aber prinzipiell ist diese OZG-Unsetzung ein Riesenthema. Es sind riesige Mittel bewilligt worden. Wobei ein Dienst, alle Verwaltungsleistungen online zu betreiben, nicht nur ein Einmalprojekt ist, sondern eigentlich ein dauerhafter Service. Das wäre schade, wenn das Portal in zwei Jahren abgeschaltet wird. Ich glaube, wir unterhalten sich darüber, wie das finanziert werden soll. Aber jetzt hat man sehr viel Geld ausgegeben, um mal so einen Portalverbund zu bauen mit Servicekonten und anderen Dingen. Aber Security müsste man da auch noch mal mit reindenken. Ich glaube, da gibt es noch keinerlei Sicherheitsrichtlinien oder Erlass, die dazu rausgegeben werden könnten.
Also dazu kann ich ein paar Details geben. Und zwar Ende 2022 ist die Deadline, dass per OZG alles online sein soll. Die Deadline, die du meintest, die gerissen wird. Und im Para 5 hat man ja gesagt, da müssen IT-Sicherheit erforderliche Standards durch Rechtsverordnung des BMI im Ministerium ohne Zustimmung des Bundesrats festgelegt werden. Und da hatte die AG Kritis dann auch mal über frag den Staat die Anfrage gestellt, dass wir mal die Rechtsverordnung sehen dürfen, weil irgendwie gab es die im September 2020 noch nicht. Und das förderte dann zutage, dass diese Rechtsverordnung, die beschreibt, wie die IT-Sicherheitsstandards für die IT-Komponenten aussehen sollen, die für diese digitale Verwaltung gelten soll, noch nicht mal erlassen worden ist. Auch einen Entwurf gab es nicht zu dem Zeitpunkt. Das heißt, die Umsetzung wurde schon lange gemacht oder auch nicht. Aber es gab noch nicht mal die Sicherheitsvorgaben. Und jetzt kann man sich überlegen, selbst wenn es die dann jetzt gibt, das weiß ich gerade aktuell nicht, wird man diese ganzen Verwaltungsdienstleistungen und Fachverfahren nachträglich Sicherheitsreihen verflanschen. Und die Deadline reißt man auch. Das kann schon nicht mehr secure by design, secure by default sein, weil man die Sicherheit als Kopf hinterher schiebt. Und auch da wieder, danke ans BMI, das Innenministerium hat es auch da wieder hingekriegt, Dinge anzünden zu wollen, statt ordentlich umzusetzen.
Ich glaube, auch da braucht es halt eine Strategie, um halt mal grundsätzlich einen Plan zu machen. Weil wenn man verschiedene Projekte startet und nicht weiß, welche zuerst kommen müssen und welche anschließend, dann hat man halt ein paar Jahre später ein Problem.
Hat denn jemand diese Strategie?
Na ja, wir haben ja gerade über die Cyber Security Strategie 2021 gesprochen. Nein.
Okay, also keiner von denen, die an der Macht sind, hat eine Strategie. Aber hat einer von den anderen eine Strategie?
Die kam halt noch nicht in den Genuss, die mal detailliert ausbreiten zu können. Ich glaube, man muss einfach sehr auf die Details gucken. Weil an sich klingt ja alles erstmal gut. Niemand wird sich ja hinstellen und sagen, wir wollen weniger Cyber-Sicherheit. Man will immer mehr und man will immer gute Verschlüsselungen. Man will das immer irgendwie schön made in Germany. Und alles ist schön. Aber ich glaube, es kommt halt so sehr auf die Details an, dass man jetzt aus einem Wahlprogramm nicht ableiten kann, ob jemand die riesige Strategie hat. Und es ist ja auch nicht das super sexy Thema, mit dem man irgendwie politisches Profil in der Öffentlichkeit gewinnt.
Das ist nichts, was eine Partei einfach mal so produziert. Sondern das ist ja was, wo du einen Verweisungsstab brauchst, ein Ministerium, was dir dazu arbeitet, um das mal zu...
Ja, also okay, verstehe ich sozusagen praktisch gesehen. Aber für mich persönlich wäre es interessant, eine Partei zu wählen, die sagt, wir haben das auf dem Schirm. Und wir machen das auch richtig. Und zwar nach folgenden Maßgaben. Na gut, anyways, macht es Sinn, wenn wir jetzt nochmal CDU, SPD, also Union, SPD, Grüne, Linke, FDP durchgehen? Mit dem Wahlprogramm, oder ist eigentlich alles gesagt? Okay, dann, weil ich euch natürlich nicht fragen werde, was ihr wählt, will ich euch aber fragen, könnt ihr aufgrund der Informationen, die euch zur Verfügung stehen, bei diesem Thema eine Gewichtung bei eurer Wahlentscheidung herbeiführen? Oder sagt ihr, das ist eh totaler Quatsch, an dem Thema mach ich das nicht fest, das mach ich an anderen Themen?
Ich mach es auch an diesem Thema fest, aber nicht nur.
Aber das gibt für dich Unterschiede?
Ich würde das auch so sehen. Also, das ist zwar ein wichtiges Thema für mich, aber es gibt ja auch andere Bereiche. Aber es gibt auch Unterschiede zwischen den Parteien.
Das ist ein Missverständnis. Die Frage war nicht, ob das Thema wichtig für euch ist. Die Frage war, unterscheiden sich in dem Punkt die Parteien genug, dass man da eine Auswahl treffen kann?
So hatte ich die Frage verstanden. So hab ich sie auch beantwortet.
Markus? Also, es gibt da durchaus starke Unterschiede zwischen den Parteien. Da kann man auch eine Auswahl treffen. Da kann man sich auch angucken, wer da kandidiert und wer da welche Themen vertritt. Also, da gibt es durchaus große Unterschiede.
Ich würde sagen, die Positivseite unterscheidet sich gar nicht mal so sehr. Für mich hilft es eher, quasi so einen negativen Ausschluss zu machen. Das heißt, einfach klar, wenn jemand aktiv, also mit einem Hackback auf Cyberangriffe, antworten will und das in sein Wahlprogramm schreibt, dann fällt das halt raus. Und ich glaube, auf der Seite von denen, die jetzt eine sinnvolle Äußerung in ihr Wahlprogramm schreiben, sind die Unterschiede gar nicht so riesig in den Themen.
Na gut, dann würde ich es dabei mal belassen wollen. Es ist einfach mega kompliziert. Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, also ich habe auf jeden Fall viel gelernt, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich meine Entscheidungsfindung weitergekommen bin. Aber hey, vielleicht, liebe HörerInnen, geht euch das ja anders. Vielleicht habt ihr noch einen Tipp, den ihr in die Kommentare schreiben könnt. Vielen Dank auf jeden Fall, Honkase, Anna und Markus, dass ihr da wart und euch so geduldig habt ausfragen lassen.
Bitteschön.
Und ihr, liebe HörerInnen, die auch alle WählerInnen seid, euch habe ich noch eine Sache mehr zu sagen. Geht wählen und verschüsselt immer schön eure Backups.